hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to I'm
just gonna come out and say it I hate
the Flintstone let's go I mean okay
I sort of respected for being the first
weekly anime a show in prime time that's
pretty impressive but the animation is
bad the jokes are cheap the stories are
forgettable and the characters just
aren't that interesting they're boring
as hell the only cool thing about it was
those household appliances that were
used from prehistoric animals that was
it I've heard of lamer gimmicks - Basin
we'll be on from the Chinese director
who brought you the awkward comedy of
jingle all the way The Flintstones movie
I guess in some ways is a perfect movie
adaptation of the show I mean think
about it's just as bland cheesy and
pointless as the original so I guess it
did job the only problem is that got
what suck it so let's take a look at the
Flintstones live-action movie you poor
fucking saps the movie begins with a pun
using the word rock and this is a
Flintstones product alright we see the
prehistoric business of Slayton company
as led by their boss named cliff my god
yes that is the guy from David Lynch's
doom and joining him is how they bury in
yet another role she'll regret after
winning an Oscar right now I have a
vision of you and me dripping with
coconut oil on a beach in rockapulco
with mr. slates fortune to keep us
company it sounds like a typical visual
from Twin Peaks but no time for that we
have the Flintstones opening to re-enact
stones
what's that you're not laughing at this
reenactment of a scene everybody
recognizes from the original goddamn
show well get used to it get really
fucking used to it
Oh universe shell it's like universe
soul except they put shell because they
shells back in the Stone Age
yeah fuck this wait a minute that
fucking holster said we were seeing tar
wars I want to see tar wars I don't care
if it's even just two people drowning
each other it's got to be more
entertaining than this I know whether
it's physical call ever till we see Fred
Flintstone and Barney Rubble played by
John Goodman and Rick Moranis Barney is
excited because French's gave him a loan
to finally go and adopt his own son why
is your barren Betty joke with some sort
of rock pun here this'll be a good daddy
Fred well you're bound to find something
you're good at
yeah sure uncle Wow the soullessness of
that scene was really quite astounding
so Fred goes home to his family will not
play by Elizabeth Perkins a CG Dino and
I swear to God one of the Olsen twins
Sofer confesses to Ella that he took
some money out to help the rebels as
well it turns out is very proud of it
what you have just done for the rubbles
is the sweetest most generous thing I
ever heard
this will be one of the many scenes that
goes totally nowhere oh forgot sit
that's not the set it's the Happy Meal
toys on display uh no no no no no Rosie
O'Donnell should not be the live-action
version of Betty that's incredible I
mean it's like boom nothing in common
instant missing of the idea quite
outstanding actually so they adopt a kid
that looks like oddly enough a real
caveman and decided to clean him up and
make him look like Jake Lloyd of course
in keeping with the cartoon the kid is
stronger than life and they end up
calling him bamm-bamm wait to the
caveman make with a cave
what an arm
you know these scenes are surest I keep
expecting a commercial logo to pop up in
the corner serial part of this complete
package so they go ahead and recreate
the bowling scenes from the show it's
not funny but I'm sure they felt like
they had to as Barney reads a poem that
he's written about his best friend Fred
since I was just a lad of ten I've had
the very bestest friend
but for my friend the special part is
what's behind his ribs his heart come on
see Jules poetry for later
that was beautiful blonde I meant every
word right gonna join me in a cold one
come on bond let's celebrate with a
Winston cigarette good hey Greg good so
he comes home only to find that Wilma's
angry mother is there played by
Elizabeth Taylor be Rob's your nest egg
to bail out that little troll next door
while my daughter has to wash her
clothes and the river Oh
does one accept the fact that she was
once Cleopatra now she's in the
Flintstones
yeah I suppose I can work backwards too
so after another Oh two minutes of a
scene that doesn't go anywhere we cut to
the next day where their boss cliff has
an exciting announcement today I am here
to formally announce the creation of
slate and company's executive placement
program hold your questions please
monkey an aptitude test will be given
granting one of you the opportunity to
crawl out of the primordial ooze and be
somebody a vice president at Slate and
company yeah I guess I remember when my
boss at my old job used to come down and
spontaneously offer the vice presidency
to one of the lower class unfortunately
I didn't get it but I showed him
good luck and may the best biped win and
exactly this is my chance to be someone
decent thank you for that
brief journey into Fred psyche meanwhile
Wilma and Betty you talk about the
excitement of their husbands taking the
exam you know Wilma if Fred scores the
highest on that test you'll be able to
hire someone to do your laundry for you
if Fred scores the highest on that test
I'll have to hire someone to revive me
that's right laughs is the only reason
you got this goddamn parole so you might
as well point it as much as you can
welcome you will have one hour to
complete the exam please carve all
answers with a well-sharpened number-two
chisel the first part of the exam
writing the sandworms
okay okay okay I'm dealt with those
jokes so they take the test as Fred
finds he had a real tough time answering
all of the questions please slide your
answer slab into the numbered envelope
provided yes please slide your big hunks
of rock that you had to ride out into
the thin paper-like objects that
probably would have been a lot easier so
Barney feels guilty for Fred and because
he's such a good friend decides to
switch the exams around so of course now
fred is mistaken for the smartest man in
the group because he apparently scored
the highest on the test which is already
kind of weird Barney was the smartest
guy there really huh who knew Flintstone
this can't be right he must have cheated
he's dense he's witless perfect actually
how does this plan work they're looking
for the biggest moron to be a patsy by
hiring the smartest person that the test
determines that's like saying we gotta
find the dumbest person who can't put
anything together let's look at this
MacGyver fellow so fred is hired into
the big leagues as cliff proudly shows
him around any gravel brain can shovel
rock down there in the quarry we
interface Flintstone we strategize you
know I can't figure out these sets are
extremely clever or rejected theme park
attractions this is my office this is my
chair my desk
am i interrupting is that my hole Fred
I'd like you to meet your new secretary
Miss Sharon Stone Oh Oh her too much oh
can I get you anything
coffee sure how would you like a cup
good answer
he also comes across a bird who plays
back everything he says
voiced by Harvey Korman it was i your
dictabird vicar what dictabird read my
beak huh cliff let's play golf we can
prioritize conceptualize in dirt instead
I will be your guide on the Flintstones
ride but there is one downside to his
fame it turns out he has to fire Barney
because apparently he scored the lowest
on the exam which of course
Barney switched congratulations big guy
Barney I can't accept this sure you can
no I can't take it back don't you like
the color you're fired fired I guess it
was the wrong color
so after another Oh two minutes of a
scene that ends on nothing we cut to
Barney and Fred talking outside you
don't worry about me Fred I've been
working in that quarry since it was only
eight feet deep attaboy there could be a
whole new world opening up for me boy
you should taking that bestfriend firing
him thing pretty well isn't he do we
miss a scene hey Fred there's just one
thing I gotta know after all these years
welcome their cannon me you got the
lowest score pal
so yeah Barney finds out that he's a
total fuck out for not realizing that
he's a genius
as we cut to our next scene with ow ow
joke hurting me ow Wilma that is
beautiful yes I have always wanted a
whole stone original Wilma is a stranger
still being friends even though your
husband fired my husband I don't know
I'm still wondering how we go to the
bathroom in this crazy world
so bamm-bamm destroys a bunch of
priceless crystals that bankrupts the
rubbles
which means now they have to live with
the Flintstones in order to get by
Flintstones and rubbles under one roof
yeah but Fred you know it's only
temporary
it better be I'm talking about drawing a
line in the sand dude across this line
you do not hey Barney like a steak rare
yeah that one's yours
hey hey barn
don't forget to wash that off before you
eat it yeah that shit let's go to
another Halle Berry sassy Wilma what a
surprise
Oh that'll be all miss stone I'll sign
those documents place them on your desk
whatever you want
secretary is very attractive really I
had noticed I've come to talk about the
roubles troubles it's gotten so bad
they've whoa look at that another scene
that didn't seem to go anywhere he
flirts with Halle Berry and it doesn't
affect the plot at all and wouldn't you
know it
this scene also happens to be about two
minutes long that seems to be the
pattern of this movie start a scene have
a go nowhere and then disappear after
two minutes that's all this movie is
just a collection of unfunny two-minute
scenes one after another
seriously Halle Berry should just come
out in the middle of the scene and be
like guys I'm really sorry I know this
movie is hard to sit through but um here
did that help
I hope that helped that's all I got look
just bear with it there's only an hour
left it'll be over soon alfresco
Oh Barry is concerned because one stone
is starting to question the choices that
cliff is making I'm worried he's smarter
than we thought he's been asking a lot
of questions you mean the guy who
actually tested the smartest is actually
asking some more questions I would have
seen that coming the cliff throws more
money at him as this of course turns
Fred into a greedy self-centered jerk
kind of like the producers of this movie
Fred did you hear what happened everyone
at the quarry today yep he fired them I
didn't do that you did - it's all over
the TV Fred Wilma who are you gonna
believe me or some busboy he's just
jealous of my hard-earned success
wow what a flints whole selector Barney
and Betty decide to leave Wilma decide
she's pretty angry at Fred - hold it is
that the Christmas story lamp I don't
get it who needs the rubbles I do I
don't need this necklace you know I
don't need this lamp and I don't need
this television set not the TV
oh no we didn't figure out a funny way
to explain how that thing has
electricity to make it function yet once
around the block you'll realize the
folly of your ways and you'll come
crawling back you will bow down before
me with you and then one day your ass
soafter gasp another two minutes scene
that goes nowhere flintstone becomes a
fugitive because cliff has framed him
for embezzling money yeah because when I
think in the story of the Flintstones I
think of embezzlement plots but Wilma
has an idea as she suddenly loves him
again I guess and she gets the bird to
tell everybody the truth you are the
only one who can help clear my husband
my my would you delicious irony thank
you for sharing it with me now let me
share something with you
if the animatronics can make my toes
stick out that'd be very insulting so
when angry mob finds Flintstone and
tries to hang both him and Barney after
Barney confesses that a lot of this was
his fault too I want you to know that if
I hear to have someone hanging next to
me I'm glared at you
I guess switching them tested and turned
out much like I planned huh Fred story
of my life
Oh anyone know why we're not hanging
them yuck I don't know something about
character development in this movie
that's a load but Wilma and Betty come
just in time as they have the bird tell
everybody what happened
unfortunately cliff finds out decides to
kidnap temples in bamm-bamm unless he
gets the bird back first we want our
children of course now give me the bird
gladly
I should have signed with Disney they
never would have allowed this sort of
thing to happen I don't know killing of
innocent animals seems to be like a
fetish wait a minute we've seen bambam
lift heavy furniture smash through a
stone wall and yet he can't break
through a simple rope but his rump like
his kryptonite is he allergic to him
science of wily coyote don't fail me now
you did it you called me Becca I guess
how's the plot thread we didn't explain
very well so far new stage the kids as
Flintstone has the final showdown with
Claire oh mama
will there be anything else mr.
Flinstone no Sloane take the rest of the
day off as well as your top no no no
it's just wait for swordfish so Fred
destroys the machine is a whole bunch of
new material called concrete covers
cliff burying him alive of course the
COTS finally arrived just as everything
wraps up and the CEO looks over the
destruction how did this happen to cliff
mr. slate I'm sorry sorry I love this
stuff you're a genius you are hereby
promoted to president of the entire
concrete division you're obviously a
murderer but that's okay apparently I
like hiring psychos here so the
Flintstones get done watching the movie
about themselves which was apparently
called tar Wars as they reenact even
more scenes which just constantly
reminds me of why the cartoon wasn't
funny
oh wow they're saying bedrock was a real
place huh
just like all great films constantly
blurring the lines of reality and
constantly failing at this movie such as
movies such as movie shots I mean I
suppose if you have little kids they
might like it dude that's a lot of money
to toss into a bunch of throwaway puns
to give credit though you can't really
blame hanna-barbera for it I mean if
some executive came up to you and said
hey we know you make the Flintstones on
only 5 bucks and three pieces of paper
now we want to throw millions of dollars
would you say no probably not look in
the bright side at least we know they
never make the same mistake again fuck
Hollywood I'm a Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to